- Today, we're sharing some
of our favorite moments
with my band y'all and
we're bringing you never
before seen interviews from
some of music's greatest names,
that includes Avril Lavigne,
and when she was here,
we couldn't help, but connect
on the art of songwriting.
(transition music)
It's so funny, cuz I-
- [Levigne] I love music
- [Anchor] ended up getting,
Well, I was gonna say as a, as
a songwriter, you write, even
with "Breakaway", the song
that I ended up recording
that I don't know why you did
but I thank you for it,
- (laughs)
- [Anchor] but it-
- You did an amazing job.
- [Anchor] Well it's such
a well written song though
(audience applauds)
in the sense of like a story,
it's such a great story-
- Ya
- and song and that's like very country,
like country music.-
- Ya
- And so I feel like, do you feel
like that influenced
you as a writer at all?
Just in how, how-
- [Lavigne] It is for sure
- you write songs?
'cause you write really well like stories.
- I love country music and
I still listen to it today,
like I have a truck and
I love country music.
- [Anchor] I have a truck
- Yes.
- I love my F-250.
- (laughs)
Her name is Betty and she's white.
- I have a Raptor, Ford Raptor.(laughs)
- [Anchor] I love it.I love it.
And so yeah, I love country music.
I mean everything jazz, like,
you know, rock and roll.
I love it all.
- [Anchor] Yeah.
- So yeah. I mean like-
- [Anchor] It's good to like
- country songs.
Country songs are amazing
storytelling, like for sure.
And like break away.
I, I was just listening
to your backstage,-
- [Anchor] Oh my God.
- in which were like slayed by the way.
(laughs and applauds)
- Well-
- Oh my God
- here's the thing I couldn't figure out.
I was like, why didn't she do this?
I was like, it's a killer song.
I was like, but I was
like, why wouldn't she?
But then I, I love your album.
So I was like, I was listening
to it and I was like,
you were kind of right.
I feel like it was a
little different than the-
- [Lavigne] Yeah
- rest of your album,
like vibe wise.
- So-
- [Lavigne] and it's funny-
- Thank you anyway.
- the lyric used to be,
"I grew up in a small town
and when the snow-"
- Snow
went, snow would fall down
- And I asked, I was like,
do you think she'd mind
if I change it to rain?
I didn't grow up in snow.
I was like,-
- [Lavigne] (laughs)
- and you didn't.
So I changed to rain. Yeah.
- [Lavigne] And like, I
hadn't like ever sang the song
until like my last tour, my
"Head Above Water Tour" and I-
- [Anchor] Yeah
- performed it on stage
and it was cool.
- [Anchor] I saw people said it to you.
- Yeah.
- [Lavigne] It was cool.
- It was so good.
- [Lavigne] But yeah
- At some point we have to sing together-
- [Lavigne] Yeah
- at some point.
(applauds)
- [Anchor] Well, you speaking
of like inspiring artists,
you inspired so many artists.
And I know Billie Eilish,
Olivia Rodrigo like
those are huge artists right now
that I love-
- [Lavigne] Yeah.
- [Anchor] as well as a ton of people do,
but they all credit to
you like for being one
of their idols that they
like listen to and loved.
Have you ever talked with them?
- First of all, it's like
so crazy to hear that.
And it's like, it's like
so flattering and yeah.
I've had the chance to
meet to Billie and Olivia
and they're like, they're
both so incredible.
And I love what they're
doing. They're songwriting.
They're like, they're just
so like creatively talented
and yeah, I've had the
chance to meet both of them.
- [Anchor] They're both very raw,
which I think-
- Yeah
- to you were as well
like whenever you first started too.
Like, and, and still now, but I just mean
I think that's what
people loved about you.
You're very honest about it
regardless of what you were saying.
And I think that people really
love, that's why I, like
when I grew up with like Alanis
I felt like
- [Lavigne] Yeah
- Alanis was that for me?
Like I,-
- [Lavigne] yeah, for sure.
- I love that. She was
just honest about it.
And I think that that's
true for Olivia and Billie
and you know, them giving you
credit for having, you know
kind of giving a partier for them
- Yeah
- [Anchor] And the sense of
feeling like they could own that
and say it, and be honest is really cool.
- [Lavigne] It is really cool.
- Yeah.
- I love what they're
doing, like they're so young
and they're songwriters and I feel
like they're like, not like
they're just like being so raw
and sincere and like writing
from their experiences.
And that's why like people
are relating to their music.
And I think when you're that young too
you don't really think about like how big
the career could be, how many
people could be listening to-
- [Anchor] it's just therapy almost. Yeah
- [Lavigne] For sure.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like that's kind
of like what my vibe was too.
Like I had no idea what was-
- [Anchor] Yeah
- like gonna happen to me in my life
or like how big my first record would be,
but yeah, for sure.